[Musique]
l'Ukraine bombardé de toutes parts par
les forces russes cette nuit à l'ouest
du pays les habitants de vives ont été
réveillés par des explosions je suis à
vive les drones volent en ce moment
au-dessus de ma tête c'est dingue
j'entend des explosions plusieurs drones
à couture situé à 70 km de la frontière
avec la Pologne vive était jusqu'à leur
épargnés par les attaques aériennes
russes dans la région de Kiev aussi les
forces de défense aéré ukrainienne ont
repoussé une attaque de drone russe
explosifs provenant de direction
différentes la capitale attaquée autant
que l'est du pays où les sirènes ont
retenti pendant des heures cette nuit
quelques civils ont été tués dans la
région de soumis à la frontière russe et
de civils dont un enfant ont été blessés
dans la ville de krasnopilliat selon
l'administration militaire ukrainienne
les Red russe viseraient les
infrastructures de télécommunication et
les propriétés agricoles une pluie de
missiles nocturne alors que la veille le
président zellenski s'est fait félicité
des positions ukrainiennes de ce mène
après le début de saute offensive
militaire qui peinte à faire reculer les
forces ennemies
dans certains secteurs nos forces
avancent dans d'autres elle défendent
des positions ou résistent aux assauts
et aux attaques des occupants major
ukrainien l'assure sur les 30 drones
lancés par les forces russes sur
l'Ukraine cette nuit 28 ont été abattus
par la défense aérienne ukrainienne